across media Outlets they're talking
about you know if a man wants to work
out and he's got muscles it means he's
he's a right wing and he's probably
going to be sexist and a misogynist I
mean what the hell is that the
government this system they want you
weak they want men particular to be weak
fat and compliant so that they can't
fight the Tyranny because when you're
weak fat and compliant addicted to porn
and unable to get outside your house and
actually be aware of what's going on in
the world then the powers that be have
more control when men are strong when
men are intelligent when men are
entrepreneurs when men are hitting the
gym that is not good for those who are
in charge and so like I said earlier I'm
personally very excited about what
Andrew's doing he's empowering men to be
better as a woman I want a strong man I
want a man that's going to look after me
and only a strong man who knows how to
take personal responsibility somebody
that's why somebody that's smart only
that kind of man is going to be able to
do that a lot of women are settling for
men that aren't particularly strong
because there aren't strong men left and
so women are miserable women are then
having to become more masculine so they
can fill that void that's been created
by Society because men aren't men
anymore